TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, hi.
I'm just building a
paper prototype here
in the Design
Tent, and I'm going
to get this design
reviewed in a few minutes.
But first, let's take a
look around, shall we?
All right.
Hey, Liam.
How are things?
LIAM: Good.
How about you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm doing great.
I'm going to get
a design review.
I'm a little nervous, but we'll
save that for a few minutes
from now.
Before I get there,
I kind of want
to know what's going
on with these posters.
It looks like you
had a Design Sprint.
LIAM: Sure.
So these posters are kind
of showcasing the work
that we did at the
Dimensions Sprint up in SF.
It was a three-day
event where Google
brought a bunch of
designers and developers
together to kind of ideate and
come up with some solutions
around these five categories.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Cool.
Can we see some of the stuff?
What is this?
LIAM: Sure.
So this one is
called Bae Window,
and basically the idea is
to keep two people connected
to each other.
It's a live wallpaper.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, I get it.
Bae, like B-A-E. OK.
LIAM: Yeah, exactly.
So you basically pair
with your partner.
And then you can
upload photos directly
to their live wallpaper.
And if you go a while
without connecting,
then you kind of see these
two circles like start
to drift away a little bit.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's not good.
All right.
What's another one of
your favorites up here?
LIAM: I think this
one is probably
one of my most favorites.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah?
LIAM: It's around
self-activation.
And the idea here is
just kind of a community
where you can share experiences
and get some support.
It's made to serve
the needs of people
who are looking for a safe
place to talk about experiences
they've had, kind of document
their own progress of working
through those at their
own pace, and just keep
track of how they're doing.
So it kind of
allows you to track
how you're feeling each day,
some thoughts or experiences
you might have
throughout the day,
and just how you're
making progress.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's a
beautiful design, too.
All right.
Let's look at one more.
LIAM: Sure.
So this is one that I
helped out with, actually.
It's around productivity.
So the idea here is that a
lot of people, especially
if you work in a
consultancy setting,
you have a lot of different
tasks and project managers
and tools that you use.
And you might spend a lot of
time jumping between those
to figure out what
you're supposed
to be doing for the day.
So this is an idea that
uses Android's ability
to share data between apps to
collect all of the tasks that
are assigned to you and then
allow you to kind of make
your schedule for the
day, regardless of where
that work is coming from.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
And is this actually like
a working prototype here?
LIAM: Yeah, working-ish.
So you kind of just
triage the things
that you want to
add to your list
by swiping in one
direction or the other.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's fun.
LIAM: So you make it all
the way through your list,
and then you kind of
have your list here.
And if you want to, you can
reorganize some of them,
just based on the order that
you want to knock them out in.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's a
really beautiful design.
This is very inspiring.
It's very material, too.
LIAM: Yeah.
So a big focus of
Dimensions was also just
what makes Android
unique as a platform
and trying to solve
for these categories
based around those ideas.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
All right, Liam.
Thank you so much.
LIAM: Yeah.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think I'm
going to go find Yasmine around
here somewhere.
LIAM: Awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Hi.
YASMINE: Hey.
How's it going?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's going well.
Yasmine, these are my friends.
YASMINE: Hi, everyone.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, friends.
So I'm a little nervous.
This is my first design
review in a long time.
I made--
YASMINE: Don't worry.
We'll be kind.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
This is my app.
It turns out, if you spend a few
minutes every day writing down
what you're grateful for, you
live a more stress-free life.
So I figured maybe I
could build an app that's
a gratitude journal.
And this is what I'm thinking.
This is the Home screen.
And when you bring
up the app, it just
shows something that
you're grateful for,
which is rated based on
a thing I'll say later.
And so it just lists that so you
can kind of remember the things
that you did.
And then you go into this List
view, and this is your journal.
It's chronological,
and it's super simple.
It just shows the things you're
grateful for and the day.
And if you double tap
it, you add hearts to it.
And you can add as
many as you want.
So as you go through your
journal, you can say, oh, yeah.
I remember that,
and I loved that.
And the more hearts
it gives, the more it
shows up on your home screen.
YASMINE: Oh, so
it's like-- so you
can see the memories that
are most important to you
and bring you most joy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You
can reinforce them.
YASMINE: OK, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And then, if you
hit the plus icon, you go over
and you just type in
what you're grateful for.
And then it just automatically
puts it in your journal.
So you just go in any time
and say, you know what?
I'm grateful for this thing.
YASMINE: Yeah.
No, that sounds awesome.
And I love it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's it.
Just simple.
YASMINE: No, it's simple.
That's the best way to start.
Can you tell me about
the other navigation
that you have going on here?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So these
are just the buttons,
and I'm not really sure what
to do here, because I put three
of them each place,
but maybe instead it's
like a button that
expands into the options.
But these are just for getting
to the List view, the Home,
and this is a plus for--
that's actually a little house.
I know it's hard to see.
YASMINE: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
there's a little house.
And these are three lines
indicating the list.
And that's just a
plus for adding it.
YASMINE: Yeah, definitely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What do
you think about that?
YASMINE: So one of
the things that you
might want to consider doing
is using a floating action
button as the main component,
which you kind of have
going on right here.
But instead of-- you move it
out of the bottom navigation
and add it to the top so it's
always floating in there.
One of the things with action
buttons, a lot of people
think, all right, let's
add them everywhere.
But it should be
tied to an action.
So you shouldn't use it
for navigation, mostly
for something like
creating a post.
One thing that you
could add is if you
were adding as your journal,
as it expanded later on,
you would tap the Add button
for adding a new thing
that you're grateful for.
And potentially maybe
then you could add one
where it's photos.
So it's maybe you want to
do a text one or a photos
one or a video one.
So that can give
you quick access
to adding a new journal entry.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
YASMINE: So that's one
potential to think of.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I guess, now
that I'm thinking about it,
and you say that, maybe I get
rid of the navigation buttons.
And the way you get
between this and the list
is you just scroll down.
YASMINE: Yeah, you could.
You could, because
there isn't going
to be a whole lot, at
least in the beginning.
One of the things you might
want to consider adding
is some form of search,
because you'll probably
want to search through
all your memories--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
YASMINE: --and remember
what made you happy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Is there anything else about
this app you want to tell me?
YASMINE: No.
I love that you started
off with sketching first.
That's one of the
things that we really
encourage everyone to
do, because then you're
not married to this solution.
Because you can go on
and think, hmm, maybe
I don't really like
how this is working.
Let's think of some
other iterations,
and you haven't spent time
coding or designing it
within a sketch or anything.
So this is a great way to start.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much.
YASMINE: All right.
Well, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
was really painless.
I'm happy.
YASMINE: You're good?
You're good.
All right, good.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
YASMINE: We try to make
it easy for everyone.
So, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Well, that's the Design
Booth, everybody.
I'm going to go start on my app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]